today in our school matters series a
report out this week shows American
students are lagging behind teenagers
all around the world in critical
subjects every three years 15 year olds
in nearly 80 countries take an
International Student Assessment it
tests math reading and science the
biggies American teenager scored worse
than students in countries like China
Canada Finland and Poland in all three
of those subjects and they ranked below
average in math CBS News contributor and
psychologist Lisa's d'amour is here Lisa
good morning this is a troubling report
not only are our American students doing
poorly relative to their peers overseas
but the gap between the high end
students and the low end students seem
to be widening yes we see things we see
that we have been utterly flat over the
last two decades in terms of achievement
for our students and yes as you describe
the kids who are performing really well
are continuing to perform well and the
kids who are performing at the low end
are actually getting lower they're
losing ground those ones the low end are
the ones that in theory should be helped
and held up by public education right
they should and and what this report
tells us is that really what we're doing
isn't working that we've poured billions
of dollars into reforms in recent years
we're not seeing it move the needle the
report also shows us what countries that
are having more success or doing and
they're doing things like having longer
school days longer school years in some
of the countries ahead of us they pay
the teachers a huge amount
teaching is a highly respected
profession in those countries they draw
people with tremendous amounts of
education into the field as a function
of that yeah so we can see what's
happening I can tell you with a teacher
for a wife that's a huge issue here's
the thing that raised the biggest alarm
for me a fifth of Americans 16 year olds
15 year olds are not reaching basic
reading levels that's very scary it is
concerning it's concerning as the
workplace moves increasingly towards
people needing to be able to communicate
very effectively read and comprehend
very effectively on this one there are
things parents can do we see research
showing that when parents read to
toddlers it actually bumps reading
scores at age 15 the other thing we see
is that when parents themselves read for
their own pleasure when they just read
on their own time
it actually bumps kids engagement and
performance and reading so what is the
level how much how much involvement
should parents have on their on their
kids when it comes to their schooling
because I think a lot of parents look at
the school's the homework and say I
can't do that I can't help well they try
it then it's a fight and doesn't go well
well it's their involvement
well not all involvement is equal so
what we do see is we want parent
involvement but parent involvement in
the countries that are ahead of us
actually does tend to look like academic
coaching more time spent working with
your child on homework supporting
homework parent involvement in the u.s.
is often measured in terms of things
like involvement in sports showing up at
school meetings these matter but they
don't necessarily change the test scores
there any good news in this question
there is there is a bright spot in this
this report what we saw in the u.s. is
that children who go to immigrated to
the US were performing at the same level
in reading as children who had not
immigrated to the US as non immigrant
children and this gap is actually bigger
in other countries than it is in the US
and this is true even for immigrant
children who are impoverished so this
piece does speak to the good work being
done in American schools and by American
teachers and that's something we can
take pride in yeah a lot of work to do
at Lisa d'amour thank you it